[Musique]
le chantier de la rue vraiment à chier
dans la communauté du maintenant
bouillonne c'est la même direction mon
père et moi j'habite avec lui avec ma
petite famille causé ce petit quick ou
gucci construit lui même la maison qu'il
habitait avec son père 57 familles comme
la sienne sont en attente d'un toit
adéquat à wemotaci qui compte au total
de 358 logement comme dans plusieurs
communautés autochtones canadiennes la
pénurie de logements frappe fort ici
bien désolé il peut compter sur l'aide
de dix neuf autres a tiqué mecs sur le
chantier mais ça se passe quand même
bien tout le monde parce que mag fait qu
this et leurs camarades sont en réalité
des apprentis charpentiers menuisiers
on a une demande du conseil de banque
pour former des pommes à une formation
directement ces augmentations
les étudiants de 18 à 42 ans ont
supervisé par rené tessier enseignant au
centre de formation professionnelle
qualitech les chantiers et une de leurs
salles de classe
ils font pas juste un kiwi pékin
pas mal mais il ya aucune malice dans
ces personnes de ces facilités pour tout
le monde parce que l'atmosphère est où
vous descendez tendue c'est facile salon
on a du plaisir tout le temps avec le
plaisir vient tous de rétention et
n'espérez de 95 % 1 seule des 21
étudiants inscrits aux cours a décroché
depuis l'hiver 2019 au pays
un autochtone sur 2 détient un diplôme
post secondaire on le leur a laissé
parler le lendemain on s'est adapté à
leur façon de vie qu'une façon fin puis
beloeil ont plus de confiance puis à une
fois que ça s'était établi mais nous
toutes vos biens en bref il est beaucoup
de coups qui sont à l'extérieur depuis
sa demande des sacrifices dizaine
d'éducateurs que de la famille aubin que
ton endroit
le fait d'avoir recours si c'est plus
plus intéressant on vient au chantier
c'est notre atmosphère que de rester
dans une classe a6 une expérience que la
commission scolaire du chemin du roy
compte reproduire ailleurs
on nous a approchés à au but johann pour
vos projets semblables
puis plâtrier aussi qu'ils veulent a
peut-être avoir claude 2 pouces pas
beaucoup de moi qui dirait qu'ils tuent
vont chercher le diplôme puis veulent
travaillant par a prêté une fois son
diplôme en poche cosy se construire à
d'autres maisons
il espère ainsi résoudre la pénurie de
logements dans sa communauté
moi c'est quelque chose qui me rend fou
c'est beaucoup plus loin et simone
montambault radio-canada web empêcher